♪
♪ ♪
♪> > EEL HLOE.RYVEON
AN
DEL WMECO.
GRDCOINURO T OORIS VIT AND
FEREWSMRON-S CPA.
I JMIMEL KIRLY D OTOECR TFHE
YBILLREN CTELOF O GLBA
TYCUSERI ASLYNASIDALO FRI
SIIVUNER.TY
TIOPRR C BOEORPOOSNSHIGIN TS
NAWEBI L ORNOMCOINLNITSIC WH
TN PRARSER WITHME A
CARIN
NCFINA T IENFAHE C SIEOCTYF O
RKW NEYO
NT EISVES IAR PTF O OUR
NINTCEENAL SIEERSRAEL CEBNGTI
EA010 Y P ORSFPOSERIVE
NBU
NESISSCA EDUONTI.
IITSAR PRLCUTILAEL TYIM
YSI
E W ARENTUR CRELY
OF CNGRI A IRSOUENIN FCIANAL
HI CY ORINTIJUONNCH WONIT
EU MEUS A OMFNRIMECACEIN FAN.
HROTHUGHE T PATSERENTNIO
EEAPLSEERNT Y QROUNSSTUEIOY B
TYM TNGHEHEN I T Q&ATI SECON
HEARNE TMOT BTOOUF O YOOR ZM
SC
ENRE.
WIWHO  BLLE ADDGSSREINS AAN MY
QU
STIESONOSS A P ABLSIEERFT
ETHNTRE PSEION.
LYLAST A A,SCIAR PTINNTPA I
TOSY'AREB WINIL WLE B
ENNTDRE IAF AO RE T WIN A
EEFR-B EKOOF O LOMCOINLNS.IC
SNNWIER BIL WLOTE N AIEIFDT
THFND E O THE WK.EE
NOIK'D I LOE T TNURVE ORO T
ENESPRIDFT THEUS M OMEUF
ANERAMICCEIN FANILHO W W
EODTRUCPEUR O S
ERAK.N
KTHAN Y.OU
YHA TNK JOU IIMST'SLW AAY
GR TTOAC B WKHIT. YOU
THEPE CAPI SOOL,
UR O
NDFRIE C AST.FA
TANDSSHI I T ARDHI TIM IE
VEHAAD HHE TLE P TURASEO
UCTRINODE JN.
FITHE IMTRS TRO IENT HCEDUDIM
HEAD HTT WRI TENENKS BOO
TTHWIOUERHI WSPYMP IE.SSREIV
EWHILECHE T SIMDON T HEE WAS
OUP T 16ND A N WOWERE AP UO
KS B19OO
GR CONIOULATAT ONSN TT,HA
JO.
K BISOOS I PLATIARCUYRL
METILYSEEC BAUN IHE TRT HEA OF
OUIT YISE'R DGSSCUIN
TRFRINASTUUCRES AE KNOW
COSSSRE INTUR CREAT DLYEBGIN
TRFRINASTUUCRE B.LTUI
IN JN, PDEONRER SEVALIM TES
TH
UTUGROHOOOHE T BT WK,HA
WO LINLNO? D
'SJOHNLI PROCFITI WRILSNG A
O
UDINCLE MESORN THA0 100
ANMNLUS IC ADRTNSLE ISLA PCE
LI T " YWNE TKORESIM",HE T
TRLLWA STEEOU JALRN B,UTOS MT
IM
TLRTPOAN C OYF ORSOUEUR OWN
MAINNEZI F HCIANALTOISRYND A
ARECLED BASN O AOO BKIL WL
BE
NUT O IHE TPR S IGINUE
MEMESOTIEX NTON MTH.
ASHNJO HEA APPNDRE OY MAN
MEAUT OTSLEM FROBC NO T N,
N,NB CC,SN MBC PBS.
S I A NIVATE OF ISINLLOI AND
DUISNG HHOHI CLD HODE
MATESID CO LNYINRI TLNOU
ANDONE H C ONUTIEDNOI DNGHA TTDE
AS ALTDUSUNROD THE CNTOURY
VIARNGTI VOUUSIO TSTRI
SIS.
EFTHERHEEOR WN YEAOU RD THE
BOHE SERAL
RE GAT
NDAPPE
ESIC.
OONEFHE TMRERS M. SEFUD I
N'DOOT STHO MND A TSISHE
VA
LOURISCOLNOURIST
DENSATINIO
N JWOHT I HASN BEE AER VY
DI13ULICT SON MTHHIOR F T
CO
TRUNY.
AS PSOLEL TEELS WTHAOU WLD
LI
OLNCN DO?
>>HANK SOU YOUC MH C FOR
ER GATENNTSOU I IPRERET ITSH
ALYS ALE P TURASE SOAKPET A
TH
EU MEUS A OMFNRIMECA
E.NAFINC
SOOHUC TUR ORE GAT SSNSPOOR
FR THEOO SCH OFESUS BIN
S,CE
ORERNT FLLO GBAITEC SUR
,YSALISOCFA C STYIEF OEW NYAN
NDRKYO ALL A OF YOUOR F
AT TINNDGOOSHI ZSI SMES.ON
T WONHA IE HOPL WILE B A
ALREVEGINEW NK LOOT ABR A
AMH
OLLINC ANND IRURANFSTURCTE.
TH SRYTOTA SSRT IN8. 182
A
MOU YNGAN ISAK TGIN
TRNGORSPTI,OO GDSOG HS,
CUAGRIURALRODUM FCERO
SONDRNHE INNAIA OHE TO OHI
DVERIRHENOW TSI MISIPPIO
NERL ONSEA.
HEON TAY W HEIS D TVECORS
GSTHIN.
HEEE SST THAPL PEOHOE WRE A
EDSLENAVOTO D NE HAV T SHEEAM
CNOCANITUPP OORTYO TDV A
CN
RTHEIWN OONTA STI
.AN
I IDTS AOR MAL E
L.VI
LSHE AS SOEE THETAMP IOREF O
ANTRNGORSPTI TOO GDSKE MOAR
TSN
IN HDAVES AGCC T TSOSEHO
SRKMAETATO N MHERTE W YREOU
LI
LE.IV
SO I YOURE A AUR RAL F
MEAR
WEREVE E IRN THENT COUOU,RY Y
DOAVOT H TEOO G TOUHRGHS THI
LA ONTRIHT WFHAHEAS W T THE
TATEINRSTE STEYS FMORHE T
NAARSON LER RGEIV G TSOET
TH
EER.
OUISTH Y MNGANAS WAMBR AAH
LI
OLNCN
.
TOOKTH ANORIER TPUT O O
ELNGRIFIIN ID,LLS.OI
2818 I AS RLLEAYOR IMPNTTA
HOREHE TH.
THITS I W E THHEANERI C
ALOP
EDEN.
THAT G NEAVEWK YOR CY,ITHI WCH
BE
MECA OFRS COUH WEITHE T
STEAGRTE I IORMPTS TNHE WLDOR,
AC T TSSOKE MHEARESTS W
T
TINTOHEAT GREAK L B ATRI
TTHEHIEIM CASGOCA W EOT NNVE
ICIA TY WTAS AWA SYMPNGRA TDI
VSTPO AYER ISICCNAESEBL
BEHEEUS T WNL OY OAYF
GEING TOW DN TOHE
MIPPISSSSIIER RIV WASOU THR
GH
GLAN UTA PYORLE CGEAL BDUD
LA.KE
EN IN3, 167 TWO ERSLOXPRE
SAEYID HRE THEDHO SUL BE A
CA
LNAEER HE.
OU YON C TCTNEHEGOHI CCA
TVERIRE LOAKIC M TGAHIN,HE
EAGRS,LAT KEHE TRI EE C
ALA,
YNEWITKOR C YYOUAN CET G TO
NENSRL OEAECAUER INTTNE
I TTOHESINLLOI,IV RER
HE TN
MITHE PPISSSSIIND ANT O TO
HE
ENCHOS
IT CY.
WTHAT T OASNST FHEIR
IMSSIESON TTHA AOU YNGAHBRAM
NNCLIOL HAD AS THEIO NATN WAS
GOWGRINHEN I T,83 10ST I W
AALRELY TIM TEETHA WON D'T
RE
TULYAL SHO ADY WLEOT L.
CAUS WEYOS MTL FKI SPMRO
EVETH RNUTOLIOHEO T TIV CIL
WA IHE TRE L ASFOT OIS HRYTO
WE BINET.EN
OFONE HE TNSEA RSO I W TTEROHE
BO B WOKASAUECSE I WTEDO
H,OW DOW OID CUR
NTOURY
LODEVED?PE
IDATWH DE W N TDEEOO D TOET G
EWHERREE W A?OD TAY
OTO DO TET GEE DNTRPE IHEO TE
ITUFUREO T MOR EELEITQUAB
WHATEAAS W RMPYLL ITAORNT
AB
TOU TTHA T WPRI AAS VYER
LEHUCK FRRBEYNIN LEIKRI TORP F
ITOLNCN ESHA CNGVIOR WLD
EWCH
GEANS TGNKHIIN.
NG CAHA H HEOW SE TDAINGHISN I
ICPUBL.
OONEF HIS F RSTIRLLEAY
CA
AIMPGNLA PNSNK IHE T 1
0S83
HWHEN F REANEN G
ALER
HMBSELY I IESN SPRLDGFINIE
ISLIILNO MOU YNG H IANN 2IS0
ILEDTNGUN RNIWO TRE STOS,
IETREYSUD RVGINASIT SPLNGTI
ASODWO W DNGOI AGTHNYIN
O T
EMAKE MSNDT.
ADHE HOM STS DEEB, AERAR PTN
INTO SEFRE L HTIMH HIGND
Y,DR HEAD H TOAY P OFFHO T
SEDE
S.BT
A DHEIDF OS THILE WHING BEI
CURUS AHEUTBO TOR W
LDVE
AANDARUTBO MNDTSKE A
ECICOMS.
THT TGSHA TOU WLDRMNSRAFO
NONL OY HIS LEIF BUTHE TIF LE
URLL A R AALNSRIMECA
ND AOF
PEVEN IPLEOEN CITSIE.
PO PHEROOMDSE S VHIETNGYER
IN
INRETESTG.
FTHEHISTIR T YNGOU SAID IS WE
OEDNE T AUI BLDAL CANRO FM
RISPDFINGELHELL A TOAY W T THE
IL
RNOLIISHIERIV WLD WCHOU
FA ATALITERE GAT NPOEWRTND A
AC T TSSOKE MHEAR N ITSN
EW
ANORLE F ASNDTHURER.OU STH
AN ALSOO TRE C AEAT C
ALAN
LD WATOU BAT LERLE CEALDHE T
ILICISNO M CGAHIN WNOANTCHHI
ULWODCTON CNEGOHI CCA
T' IS
ONLYBO AUTLE6  9MI.
SDAN A AHIRDHI THING WCH
ALACTU P WLYASOHH-OOPO
AEDT
TITHE MEEC BSEAURY EVEDY
TH WT GHITNG GASOIO T BEAY W
TO
OXP E,SIENVE WAS A MORAJ
RING TRHIONO T CHECTNE T
SOLWHEOTETA TESHE T R OTFHE T
NSTEAER MKETTHE TIM TE.
ATTHOAAI RLRD WASOI GNG BO T
E
EDCALLHE TIN ILLSALEN CTR.
HE
W WKEORDHIT A FLOELW NED
OUENEV DHOASGL WAT GSERE
RIOU TLSHR LOUGHTEIFN I
POOCSTI THIET G TE. DSON
EDPASSSI M AASVELISRETU
FRINTUTRASUCN PRELAHEND A T
N
OMPTT WLYEN B
T.US
ASIT WND UTACAERPIZELID T,HE
CAL H T TADOOMEAK SE TEIM
USBEF CAY TEHEOTID D NAV HEOF
TH
EY MEONIRO T HERI ISH
RSBOLAREETO T G AAI PD
OSLMT
INNOTH D TGO IIGTY B HD.
ONBE D O IENOERRD TN OPE U P
AGCHIC G TO,HEAKATRE L AND
THES RTF O ISINLLOI TO T
HE
ALGLOB MKEARTS.
SOLNCNS TAWHIAR EE,LY H
GNMPCAAI I FEDOR H ATND WE
AS
LYFAIRSSUC SCENLFU I
INCI PEOHAEPL TS TTHIO
SH BLDEON DE.
TE WHEAN P TDOURUT RARAL FRSME
DANBO ANY I WDYHO NS LOT
ING
ANEAR CIG BYITR OAL S
ATTR
OPORTNAL EQU F WTIOONGHIT
ODEREVYBYLS EE HOWO DOU Y DO
?THIS
REUYO CRAEAT TATPONSRTNIO
OESUT TSTNF IRAECTRUURO TRO
EOTGE PEPL THE.
INSO LASLNCO WYAI FRL
SUCCSFUL YS A ANGOU AYEMSSBL
MA
T WTHAAS WOR MEOR IMPNTTA
HESWA TDUNT IROCE TSHI CCEONPT
ONSEBAD RY HENSLA CY'CAME ARI
NY
HAEMST T Y ITFLD BOUUI
ECONROICOM POU W CESGRS.E
WTHISASMEUN FDAALNTO THE T
VIEWF O T WHELDND THE
TAEDIT SENSTE HY CRYLAAS W A
WABRGIN AAMAHCO LINLN WASN A
EA TWIY GERYHE W VER MUCH
UITOIN BINLDGSTNF IRAECTRUUR
ANDFSAR TIFO T PAYOR FHE TM,
TRNTEAL.IFARFS
ANHE TY DIDHISHE TALY C
DLE
ETHE ORAFOO GDLI FEES.NG
EVMI' NTE QERUI WUR SEY THYHE
CA
TEDLL IHA TT.
TOWAS  CUI BLD AALANSVELL OIR
THENT COURY.
CTON CNE MHE TSE RORAJIDIG
RIVEMSYS STE COUAIERS R
OS
OTOOK T IFFNHE FNGLOOLWI
DE T IDEN0S 1HE84 ANDHE TN
CAMEHI TSUG HNTE IESTERAT
SYLL REMEAYOO TK OFFAU BEC
AL CEAN E CSANDEEXCDEHE T
GRTH.
APATWH H WNEPEDINNHE LLNCO
PRSFITSPOROSEIT LETL CALAN
OUPRF O SLDGFINIE WAS TTHA
NE AHA TTLANY P WCEREHE THE
LCANATAS W A A CTIJUONNC
ON
AWITH RTHNOERYSERIV SNMTE I
THASELL IOIINS, A L OOT
F
ERCOMM D ACENDMEELEVOP WOU
KETA. OFF
S TDHIERS I VY LTLITEWN KNO
BU
W HTE AASUSER NVOERLA PNN
.HE
EDLA PNN A TNOW AT THE
TIRSTEEC OONFS THIAL CANIN
CA
EREDLL H A OENNS IE LAK
ROHUN.
IT WRSOUEASEV NERLT BUI.
I
AWHE TNS PLA ANDOI DNG
RE S OHRNGETOMHIEVF O N
ENHE
NKND OW A LUTBO TCOINLN
OFRS COU HEEOV MEDN OO TE B A
LA M TEROEAK AEIT LTLIT B
ONREMO MEY.
HE WAS V AY SFUCEUCSS
L
ERLAWYEND A HIN KDF OEDRO DPP
OUOLF O PICITS 1NT UIL4.85
HEDAN W TNHEIMNT IER
,
ICAMERROSA' G RNGWI AIDAPE PAC.
P
SEN UP84 1 WHA H,PEAPNST I
CRHISTE TS AAJ MORIT CYN O
TH
ER OETH OND EF IT.
IAGICO A DPYEIT LTLCH
PYSWAMRE ANA O LEAKHI MICNGA
T WINHAESEC BOM M AORAJ
SHNGPIOR PT.
ANEC BESOMHE T EIEASSTOR P
INY CHEITHE WHEN T C IALAN
S
SHFINI A FEDORST LTEA ANOER
.CADEDE
AN0 1BY90OPHE T PNATULIOAS
SO EXPSIVET IESEC BOM THE
TSTFAESNGRO GWI IIT CYN THE
ARLWOD TTHE
-OTURNCETHF-E-
URNTY.
WTHATIL FASAC BATITEDS TYHI
IDHA TTIN LLNCOHAMPNIO
WONALGTEHIT SOUNVE D
ASGL.
MEVENEORTAMP IORLYNTHE T
ILENISNO CAIALTR R
OALRD
HWHICEAAS W RY BLT TO
MEPPSULENTT WHA WNG GOI UP
AN TOW DNAL CHEANOM BSEC
ESTH
ESLOE NGLR RTAINDOA I THE
RLWOD BY0. 185
IL UTNTHE T WIV CIL.AR
AM BITECAJ AE MORRA TITNS
DUTROE TINURGIL CHEIV W.AR
SOEEP THO TSE TWO INGHISN
D. MIN
ETHESWORE A TSEMM IEN
DETSPMLOENHEN I TRYIS HTOF O
THNT CEOURYN IHE TID MSTWE
LI
STS NKEAN I A MART TO
NSTWEERTSAR MKEHEF O T
SOOIRNHE PS.NT
'SITBA GLOONZALITI IN AER VY
SALSMLUTSEEN BN I A VYER
GRINGEN S.SE
WNO WTHA HPEAPNS INHE TIVIL
CWARLOESOM A?NG
W KWENO LHA WTCOINLN SAYS.
WENO KWBO AUTHE TOU HSE
DIDEVID SECH,E W TOT NEHE
NNCLIOL D DGLOUAS.ATEBES
TESTI ARNG GDOIOMO T SFE O THE
ALTEMARI SE HDAIALIT LER TLYHE
FIAT DTEBH WEITNTE SVE
LADOUG 1 ISNE'885 H RS
NIUG
AFOROREN SATHET A TIM TE
TAIAGNSASOU DGL
HLAUGSTR CADONLEOLDHE T
ISLIILNORAEM DOCARCTI P
AD
ATHA TT T TEIMREHEER WEOT N
DICTRELYCT ELE HEDEAM BECEHE T
RNASETO.
SOTHAAP HNEPEDAS W I
N
INTALKUT AGBORYLA SVE
AD ME
OTANRHERG AENUMT.
TH D WISASINURGHE TST FIR
.BADETE
HEOUDAI Y ENO KW,ANRYVE M
PAI'M SIPHRARAO,NG TNE B ON A
FUAEQL WTIOONGHIT EERYVEON.
TSO ISHIS L'SCOINLN OIE VWF
ECROICOM P TESGRST Y
VEHA AHT RIGO TFF OEROU YR
LAROR FAY P T YTHAAVE
ETHTUPP OORTYNI TOEN ASCHED T
OMECONICAD LRDE
Y DWOE MOUOV
P? U
HOWO DOU Y A BIDVO TNGEISHI
BADS W AOOLLNMA A LOU YREIF
EDDOOM F TO?MIARNG
HOOUO D YO D THA?
ISE ILTHARS I PFT O THE
ANERAMICTE SYS.
ITFDIN OWN GRO UP TOEA LRN
INTO HURIS.RY
RE TTHEE M'SORO T ITHA T
NTH
.AT
SREHE IHIOM SETN ENGVEOR ME
EX
.TICING
ITHISS ATHERID SELO PNDT A
HOETH WCO LLEIN SLNRYTOHA TT
REIN DLYUR HGISOR ST O IF
WO NDOTALLLE EXI BUTS IT'
STSHI EENNGRAEMTM FROICOL PITS
WH
HIC WLDOUAS LTLYOU RGHRO FM
THEMETI HSEA LVEHE T GERENAL
AS
TMBSELYE MOORLYOU RGH85 14
WH DOUASASGL PHESSE TSAN KSA
KABRNEASCT ALL AINOWG FOR
ITTERRY.ORNF S IVELARY TN
N NCLIOL TMECOSS TOHI
IOIZALATNT THAHA WTS IE
MPLYAL I HTAORNTEER OERTHE
THAN EINNDGRYLA SVES IE W
STL NEE TDO PAYTT A TTIENON
O
ASINFRREUCTRTU84ER P 17 IS
ESREPRVETAENTI TOU HFSE O
GALTULYESIV A V LYER
GON
CHSPEEFNE O O LIS HGEONST
ESEESPCH OVE ER
UCASFRTR
RETU.
ISWHY T ITAMP IORNT TOAV H
ERA
S?ROILAD
WHS IT I M TNEAHEO TEA H
HLT
HEOF TEUT FURF OHE T NIOATN?
LIHONOL TTHTUG IAS W
SEES
IANTL.
ACIN F HEASRAIS DPANGGI
TIDESENOL PKT AHE TIM TORE F
THENCTOL CLEGINHI TSE HUGD A
ONNATIUE IALSS
ININD UPIL UNT.KE
LIN'S ERAY MANF O THE
NGUNFODI F ,HEATRSAN MY
HESOUTERSHOUGIR THTHE
FEUNLRA FTRNGDI S WTUUCREAS
NSUNCOONTUTITIAL.
JARO MSONSE HEIMD SLFAIN I
ANLNN AUAGEES MSA, BVE ENOREFE
TH IAN CALIK LE THE IADE I
S'
INOT TNHEON CIOITSTUTN.
THSEAS W USD AN ARG AENUMT
TAIAGNSOR F D BADECESOREFEHE T
CI
LVIAR W
.
LSITCOLNUGGEEDSTN I86 10
IERTHE A SESSI T OONF
HE
HESOUTRNTA SS.TE
HACAINN  G TSOO IONT
WAINGT A BONYRE SECTOU RTE
BEHEEUS T A IRESN
INSAASSS PIOATNTLOP
ATT.MP
S GHEET IHE TRE C TNHEARILIV W
ARSTTS.
INSE PRO TTICUNGIL CHEIV WAR
LI
SOLNCN'DEC RORERS I VL WYEL
KNN.
EENWH HMBAD H E IDEEDDN
E'MESOONY VSERAS BICSA MESSGE
ERREWE VND FYOULIOATNA IASDE
ONAI RLLNGSI AOA BTS THE
EC
POMONICS.GRROES
WHE THEAV F?OR
FI
FTRS O ALL THE
TRNEONSCTIAIALNT R
OALRD
MEBECAY V AERUL POPAR IADEN I
TH.84 10S
N,HNJOSOREMONTEI HERORN F
IDPRESTENIN AGAHA BSTUCNNA
GNMPCAAIN O TTHA.
HEAS WNE OF OHE TIR FST
REBLIC REPNLIUBCA
AR PY
NDOESOTOM CELO ANTNG U TILHE
MI
h  1D-9tYNTCEUR0S 185.
IN R NHEEWCAUBEPLITY PNARF O
CO IS AINGASTVE SLARY AND
FO
T TRHENTNSRACOLENINTA
RA
ADRO.
OLLINC HNAD RNTREEPSEIVATES
NOILLIIS C ATRENALISS H L
YR
TKNEWOR IHEMP ONCTAEFT.
HSOE FORAVST THAN I ONEF O
HISLNN AUAES MGESASHI WERCH WE
TSAVEON UHENIHEPE SEC
HSE
IOMENTHO ANS WCH BLEUNF O
OTRNG THIS.
IHES TIR FST PNTSIREDEO T
DORAEL TEGSA MPHESGE
OVHE L TESHEEG TELPHRAS A WE
KNRO FISM H IRYTO TNHEIVIL
HWARENT SPE A LOT OFE TIMHE T
TE RAPGRHYMOO BNGET GTI
DI FCHATESHEMRO TUSAR VIO
STTBALE.
YRSFITFRSEA O THE WAR V
YER
YBADLHEOR F TNI UON.
OANDRS CFOUCO LEIN'SLNHO ST
FOOWINER GGENS.AL
RY'SHE TISGIN HSRO TOP
ER WE
NTHEODEE TE. B
MANDTOS OFHE TMRE AHE T
FEL GERAL T ISTUTNSUR O
AR
E RHE TDLRAIOANGINRS W
HE
MECA GSERENAL.
TH BAT LER AOMECE IIVCTE
NS TERAENNTCOINLTAAI ROALRD.TH
HE
AS'SRE W RVE ENBLAREMKA AT
GH HEEI T OTFHEIV CILAR W
TH
GISODWF AUL BEDODLOSH
LIVE000 POSEPL LIR TEHE
OR MEAJYITOS LE T IMHENHE T
TMPCASIO VOAR DSEAISSE,
HTHEYOEAV NDE IAT' WHANG GOI
ON BAUECSE I IS NOT C
EOM
GALON 2IL TLEA003 YER LRSAT
.HE
A A'SNOCAT OFALED MIC
CHSEREAR.
HESHABSTLIHO PESATGY
UTSTINITE.
IHENDOU TAP P WSERREE
TAUT ASBOSI UNGIN DISTCTFEAN
OMDAN S T OEFNIHE UON CAMPS.
S DHEOEOT NVE ENNO KW A
UTBO
S GERMT JHEUSEARSBOUTT. I
SIAW IAT LERNHE T ASHIRCVE
HIRFO TEP ESXC R AT GLLEAYDOO
EAID.
'SHENNUR O I HATOVORE TAN WTSO
DOEWHI TS.
S TNTO SEEEE NEW WSAYF O
ATUNMMICFGIN ONS TRAGRTPOINCO
GO G OS,F UTIETNG TSOHE WRE
WEEEDO TE B.
O OINNE TFHEGE BIGT SSTORF O
FO
LLOP SWOT TSHA HENS SIGNT I
ALAWEE TREHRER VYMEUN FDAALNT
LA
ES HEOMCTADTE A AHI WCH
OS
LEPEOPALAS BIC FRAD THE
LMORA ACTAB ESTSHLIES
LA
NT-GNDRAOLLES ANDF O
CO P TSEHE RIFACIC
LWAIAY
TACT,OAW LCT A WLLUAYCHHI
HEVEGI T FAN LDHEOR T TNSRA
CUET MAL RAIOALRD.
TH
ATAS 12.
FOTHE GOWLLIN HEA YRELS AO
TSSPAESIO NHEATLNANGAN BKI
AC
THORS I FIRHE T FE TSTIM
BLESTAHEISSEN GRELA DOL IRS
ROU NLIOATNAURREYNC AND
HEBLTAISO ASLSENC IOMOAX T T
PARFOHE TAR WND AGUR DIN THE
RWAHE TNI UONRE INCESAS
SERTHE'Y V AERMA SLL TAX 3%
$OVERO080 TAY P ITS IHE T
FIOM ITNCE TAXEA REPDLE IN
I73VEEL BIEN ITOM CES
CKBAN I91 13.
IBUT WT FASWASTIR AFY OHE T
ALTINAON GERNMTS FNGANINCI
IS
SIXP EEN T OVENTHAEV LEL.
TH VAS W A IYERNTORMPTA
VEDET.PMLOEN
SOS TLLHINSAP HPE THE WNHE
VILAR WSBET GTYGURKS VICRGBU
IN A86 13 TNHE T WARS I
,OVERLNIN LCOOS LESIS HE LIF
IN
H86 15 ASE'NAASSSSITDTE A
FO'SHE TERAT.
L HTIS LACEGYESIVN O.
HEHES I TOS MTNGMA AZI
ART
TOFHE SRYTO,CO LINIE'SLN VW
OFMICO ENO PCGRES TSHI
BUNGDI IRURANFSTURCTEYEA RLL
CO O OSUTTH AFNOT PERARF
HIESY PCHN I 1784IT H
ACNVLYAL ITEEND AOT VE.
ESAS W D TNEIGDOIF LTP UOT N
A  V BRYIGUTEOT B ITE LIFD
I IUPF WTAS INOWHA SLL WERATS
HEDENATTE84N I 1 A8ND
TRELEDN OHE TOILL IIN
SMI
IGCHANANAL
LI TN OLISHE OYNLDERE PSI
NTH
IOS P ADENATTETONV IENR.
ASIT WAD HN IHE TAC BKF OIS H
NDMIEI BHENG TNNOVOWORAT H
DO
E WO DHI TETSNG BR?TE
OWHO DSEE W U TOGHNECOLY
?
DOHOW  RE W DLLEAYOHE TSHI TNG
WELL RREEAYOO GD A TT MOEAK
TH
ET AIS BOURTE CORRYNT F
NEEREVYO
THREE A THENC PRIHIALIP TSNG
CO DIIS TREVEDGATHA A
TINE
LEIVCYGA LES ON.
HEDPINSRELE W AHOEW N
ONRANETIROF O PVEESGRSIGE
POANTILICIS FLONKRA L
,IGWRHT AAM JESM,DAIA SOCL
S,FORERMINHE T LLNCOAYIG HHW
WHHAS WHE T FSTNAAT NIOL
/WEASTOUTES RS GTEOEGHHR TOU
TIRESQS UAYLB AANAN S
CIFRAN WOSC,ED NASAMFT AER HIM
NSDAN I BREPIDY. HIM
IN IAC FT WASOR BN J OTUS
FFTH
EIN LLNCOHW HIG TAYHE
WITSPAL WREHE IORAS B AN
LO
ERST
STXIS.
SIT IDAL CLEROHE T CROAD OF
A.ERAMIC
ANOUF O CHEERS TIN'SRE LLNCO
ERL ALOVY MTA SE'TE HNS O HER
LI
NSCEE PLATE.
INSPNATIRIO.HI TS
ADE THRO T ISNOUSHI CERRYNT W
EE
ERLYAL TBLRIENG GOIWA FORRD
OFROMT PNEAR TF O CHE
NTOY
TOERNO ATH.
ES FALCILYHEMRO TSTID MWEO T
ETHES WT.
9 1IN91 ANG YOUIR GL- -HI W
TE
NHEISEAKEROW TES A CVOONY TO
EPLEXORHELNIN LCO H
HWIGY
OFROMST CNEOA TO T OERTH.
IT
OM CES TOHE TND UEIAENBL
COSIONHEYUSRE A JT
FUAWL.
OSOMEF THETE ROUS LEIK
PIRAREE THASIL T T GTO
OH
TAMOUNSIN ANDTSES DEREO PEPL
EARAY S HG,IN DOW WOEAY P FOR
ISTH?
DHOW D WOES? TOHI
TH IIR FSTASADE WHE TLNIN LCO
HIHAYWA TT WAS 1391 THE
NCT RSCOFTEP OCIIN FAN ITFI
HASWA T S ITT BULHODE
PRELATYAN FIND.CE
SO EENRENTPRREUAS WLL REAY
EIETH H TRO THE PACRDAI SD
WE
SEE NDYEBOMODOO T DHI TS.
YEVERTS C 4ENO AUC BK,
YORE NNG GOTOIO T
IS H
ATPRIVONE M.EY
ADAN IOTM NOI G TNGO
CO
IBON CTRE.UT
GU'YOREONGOI T FEE ND
EREL
INFUND TJUG ST DOOHI TS.
HE TONY DAI'T RNOSE EHUGSO
NEMOY.
THEYETRIUB SSCRSBE INCDILUNG
ROWOODSO WWILNND AGA A TINNKHI
HEIVEAV FKS BEUCR O
THSOMEGIN.
THIS I TSYRIERBL UNDFINAEDNC
BU
S DTOEEAOT N RAPYLL HNPE
ETIUNLWEENISHORESEC BOM
PR
TIDESENN I95 1 T6HE
IN HTARSTE AHWIGAYCTND A
TECREA TSHEAR LSTGEAYIG HHW I
TR
DIETINF ILAONTEDJ AUS FDOR
SDATOY'RSOL DLAT IOU WIDLD B
AT00STEA 6ONIL BLIROL-DLA
OJEC
WNOE WE FAC ATEA LST
T$6NLLRIIO PHI TSLPOROSAOR F
TETH 2N-LLRIIO ALLDOARNRIMECA
BSJON PLAY B PNTSIREDEID B
SO AITS W AH OOT LFY M SRITOES
ISTH ISIK LE MIFY F BKN O
INTUTRASUCTO HREIS,RY
E,NAFINCEL TNGLITO SBOESRI A
UT
PTHE BPLEOEINEHDSE THE IASDE
AN THERI P HIPNCLESEER IER VY
POHAULRF T D YTOUD NOEEO T
MAHE TSEES INV.ENTMTS
THOWS I HE WIN LKUR O
ESCITI T O,UR ONSOW,M FURAR
FI
RODSEL FM-TOA CSTTCOO-AS.
LI'LLOUVEEA YIT WH OHI TSNE
THGIN, WERE AY VEROO GDT A
TH
CO LATINLL RLNEAY
IFRSPEOND WHI TSDE IAHA TT
IN
ONVANOTIOULD NOTNL O LYTIF
OUCO EMINOC S FTITAONOR
TRENURREEPNEIPSH, TS NEW
LOCHTENO A BGYUTIFOLS LT TIRHE
SIRSPIT THA TTSSHI I
AS
ONRAPITI.AL
LL SWETIRU TLYELIE THIS
NVWNE I OTIENONRHI TS NEW IADE
ISONGOI TNG CHAHEE T WORLD.
TH
IATSHA W ITNK THIES MAK US
ERICDS ANANSHA TT' OAR PT
FTH
E PHATOR F
RDWA.
OONE THE R ISOEANS W
TERO
BTHISNDKOO A I HEAV TOEL TL
YO
U LNE O STAS OTORF AECDNEOT
AB
T.TOU I
IACTERO B IARKWDSEDTA SRT
OUIT WHHE ERA AND THE
PA
WEMNDIC AERE IN. NOW
LI TTOSWODSRI FEN INO KW
OS
OF PPLEHO W LTOSDSRI FENND A
MYLEON CDOFESNC I YOUNE KW
DYMESOBOERHO W P IHEISDS TNHI
LYUG TNGHI.
TTBU ILEEV READHIOM SETNG
AB
TOURET BTELOC SIA
UCASFRTRETRETU BRTEIN
IOUCEDATLNARA INFURRUSTCTE
ROS,RI B TESDG,,NEUNLS
RA
ADROS.
OALLSE TFHESHI TNGHA TTOME
LSIT ALD BOUIIR TSHEND> > AE.
CEITHRNCFIONDEEND GIV UESS
INMESOTHOPTOG  HEOR F.
AS IITS ONRAPITI.AL
ITDAN WT THHAOU I WOVLD L TEO
KE YRST QUENSIO.
THS E'AHO WLECH BUN OF
SORSTIEN IHE TOO BK IT WAS A
PUOY JO TTE WRIGIV LINN I
TH
OLAE ND LINLN AEOND PEPL
EKAS MONOW H LIDG D ITE TAK
YO
W TUOTERI TS?HI
IELDAI W AY M LEIF.
TH IS A ONOINGNGTO SRYND A
HE
O ALPLL YFILOU WL
BUNTCORITE T TOSHI E TORFFTO
IZREALT WEHAE W NODEE TO. D
REWED  A TAC BK JO IIM TNK.AN
HAES Y T V YNKOUUCYER MH
JOHN
OSTJU TTA SRT USFF O,EEF BOR I
EVEN A ASKST QUEETNIO L'S
AGCOENURRY EEVEOEON TLE PEAS
YTEENRWNROU OIOUE QST IN
QTHE&A BOX.
AN GEE KPNNGOI OHA TTAS BIS.
ARETH TASFIF W AAI MNOURC
NCOF IEOM BKAC T DN,HEONK THI
NNCLIOLOU WLDE B IOR FAVF O
HIIF TERARAY TFSODNAY S O
ACHIN?
>> THI TNKLE WHEHOFAR TIF
ULFORMEDPRA OV TOE BOT N
EN D TGHOO WT WEEE NODDE T
T IDONFMSER O
TRFRINAS.TUUCRE
THHES I TLE WHOUM ARGTEN
HENGRI T C9t 1h
TUENRY
FFTARIE WSER UODSE TUNDE SOM
INTUTRASUC.RE
TTBU IOTAS W NNO EHUG
.
IST I AD GOOAY WO TIN FCEAN
THEHI TSNG?
LWII LLVEEAT THAO T THE
NSORSTIA T T,OAN FHEINALCI
TALANYS.
LD WIOUHI TNKT WHA WE DOEE ND
B AISASADRO-BTA SEDUS
ABIE
OWAYAN FFINNGCIHI TS.
IHEETRST' PPRLIUBC- OATIVER
HROTHUGON BDS ORGHHR TOU
AXONRB T SESO MYANSARO PPO
LE
HAET G TTIS DNSSCUIOOI G
ONUYO DES I'TNV ITNR YOU HSEOU,
TEE NDLA ROEP TCEHENGEA HTI
THONIR A CINTIDION O AGLL
F
ETHESSHI TNGEA WR. OUT
ONOU Y D D'T TOT YOUE'RF
GOKLOINT ABL PROSEM.
SOSE HHEOU IS OURIO NAT ANND
IT
NOE DSODEE T BEED FIX A,ND
UPPUEDAD, EW AT NECHNOGY
WEODEE TSSDD ARETELI CMA
CHL, GEALHEF O TNG TSEHI
S.SO
OE W D AEE NDHAND TST IHE T
RRCUENMEART GUOW,NT HO D WE DO
HTHISADEF R?ANINCE
>>ONEN MTIATNN IOV INEF CHI.
SEESLYND LRSENO KWNRY STO
SWA AUE DL CGELLHAENVEEL BIE
N OITRHAOT T LTCOINLNAD H.
DAN AIT LITETL BUT ABOHA TT
ER FOTHNCUD AIE BEUTGA AIN
PMOST APLEOE A NREOT OREWAF
TH
E.OS
>> TTHHEERLL ROEAD GYOO
STS.IE
EYTH BHOT HPEAPNT AREIF DFE
NTI
S.ME
HETBU TEN INVRSTOTO SRY WAS
TH L FATOR TCOINLNO GET TO
ONINSHGTADE H HAKO T THIE TS
D GOFUAWL RTEOM CE TOUHRGH
AT GEREES LAK, T TOUHRGH
HE
CERIE DALAN,HENOW TUD HNSO
RI S ARNDESETOMIM OAC EH
FTH
RL OEVEDANSOU RTE.
OANDHEENFT WNE H WNAS O
VO
T ITENAT GHEREAK LEST I
WOD G SETCKTUND AHE TYLD WOU
THAVEO PHE TOT VEOO LSE
WIHE THY PCASIL LORAB.
SWE CTAMITP U WS THHIA, IDE
LLTELIRAIG DYESTDNE IN O THE
SHHE WREE HAD HHE TSEOL PLS
PRTYH WIS I HAD AIC PFRETU O
IT LOU WLDTIFT IP UND A TYHE
HAHE TSENF IETALABLUO BYS
TH FOU WLDHEATLO TOT VE UP
.GHHIER
A WITASLL REAYRLE CVE
N NTVEIOE MHEAD AOD MEL OF
.IT
AD H AEN FRI CDCTSTONRUO T
E ODPRUCNWNO IYSHE T SMTE
ONITSMHSN IT AAS W BULUTEAIF
LO CINOKG
FTRA.
BNOTSLTUI ASAR F A I KWNO.
DYNOBOSE UDT I TREHES I
NABOBLYT TOTHA NUC MH
DEE
FORT. I
E DLUAHA CENLLGEAS WLNIN LCO
HA IOM SE WUESSSHIT
ESDEPRONSI
OONE HFISHEWE SETIETSAR DD,
ATTH AAS WNNUT RDGLEE.
DLMAYN IE LOVH WIT HERHE S
AND HE B IS
EFERT.
ETHE GY VSEREP D.SSREED
TH A IESY MARWE ONSOR BEFE
TS MHEEE MYAROD TD WHOAS W
VE
TIPOLI SLLCAYT INTVYAV.E
HNEWRYENY CLA.
GRITP U WT THHAHO WLE
AURLTET TNDHA LLLISOUVIE,
UCKENT.KY
: : :
>> .
>> THAT TT'ST WHANEAP HPE
D.E
OTID D N FHTIGHE TL DUA IF
WE
HOU WLDEAVOS LTCO LINLN I
NN IMANE WHITHA TS
YUNCOTROU WLDE BIK LE.
ODGOST QUEN.
THKOU Y.
I>>FOU Y COUNE O T TNGHIO
SPRA IDNFURRUSTCTEY MEONN O
OUATWH WLDT I BECK QUI
.
HA>> TASST' E FY MORE.
OUATTH W H BLDEARLTEAHC
E.BE
OUSCAE T ONEFHINGS I
OVDISCNEDER INGRI WTIHE TK BOO
BA
SWACKRDS IHE TRE AREAS MVESI
INTIESN TFMSER O
THHEALOVRECA C WAGEREHIT
ITMMCOUNFSIE O AOL COR TNDHE
ORESTF TOU CRYNT.
SIT IY VER ANDVENL DIDIVED
IN
AYOU CNTTH NORF OHE TY CIT
AVWE HE ALE PORTHA OFEA R
YLL
HGOODLSPIOSTA TUT B STHOU
SI
ODEFGOHI CCA ISOT NHE T
HESECA TUG SRETR TINGLGOY STA
WENOPS WHYAS BN THEAN MYO T
SA DOW HOY THE HEAV A
BAOABRD-D PNLABOVE ERY
EN DTSECIC BTASHCEA HLTE.ARYGE
WE TDEEOOM C UE WITH
SO AINTHG TSHEID COV CSIRIS
EX
TSEPOSSE IIEQUNEITS.
HAS WERIORBLAU BECOMSE SIT
E
LEPEOPTID DN' AAV HE OESCCSR
GO
NT IOHE TOS HTAPILHE TY WER
AF
HEIDRA TLD CYOU NOTAY POR F
.
THARS I PFT O THEOC SLIA
UCASFRTRRGRETU A
ENUMT
OLLINCN WLDOUE HAVMB ECERAD BY
TH
AL EEQUMERE TATLANT C AEUST
E VEAYER L WSTEUL SHORED TAT
EV FODYBY ARLAIYNDAL EQU
.LY
OUOF CHEERS TYEN HAV'TND A
HA'SAT WY TTHE NDEEO T TKALH
TOUABT AKIALNGUTBO
IN
UCASFRTRRETU.
>>INHIT L BLNCOEN IOR FAVF O
AINETE IMET VO TO KPEEUT O
OF
HE TRA INFURRUSTCTEL? BIL
>> I D'TONNK THI HELD WOUE'V
AOKLOEDT TTHACI SPEYCAFILL
EH
AWAS BIGIC PRETU T.NKHIER
CTHENTTIONNELR RALAIOWDOA H
BI AF OREIC PTU WASHA TT?
THPURN THE RBEOBRON BAR
ERAND ADE MUR TNGRIMHEND A
GTTPUIN OHE TMESN RONVAERTI
STH
SEER I AOT L O BAD TNGHIS
TH
ATAP HNEDAU BECFSE O
EXSTIONSNIMICO ENOIC PCOLSIE
BT DNOOUOWUT B HAN COU YEE S
TH?
ONI DW K'TNO WTHAE HOU WLD
HAHTHO TUGO T BEON HTES
AOUABTIN LEM ITE VOET BUTHE T
QUFONTI OIS HE TIMTAS WN'
RNGOVENT WTE B NUTOT
NGENSPDIHNO EUG OON MEYNHA WT
EDTTMAERHEO T TRE GESATT
NUER OFEO PE.PL
ITHAT AS TGHOUOURIG NHT
ASLLWI P OSN TTHAUT B IHI TNK
LD WHEOUE HAVOO L ADKET IT
ALENEVTU W HLYEY VASER
-MOPEN TDEINDOEW NAS IDE.
>> ACOINLN FNDCKDERERI
DONESSLA KH EWACTH OERL WEL
UTELLBOS AUTIR THE RPOAPRT
AN TOW HTHAIOEL RATHINSP
EDVALUIC POL
S.IE
>>ND A MURRIDENG PELAARNC I
TH YKOUEE BNEN FRINDDS A
IEENEM
T WOMHA ILD COUL TELE H
WEOUEDOM DNTASGL I TOHE
WH
EITOU HSE.
RS COFOUGL DEOU WASAS A
LICOACMPHIEDSH TNDERNK A
SPNDRKE ATIBO ALI
ISONT.
ROHE W TTEWOOB AUTHIGRIOAP.ES
SHE IZI AMAENG H ONSPE THE
WH
SSEOL I OUEFRYLA SVEND A
OMECONAL EICQUNDYIT AHA WTE W
OEDNE T DO.
THS PBABL B NYO
TEETR
ONPERSOUF I Y WTAN TO
TADEUNRSND AO TEA R
D
ERFREDKICASOU DGLS.
GL DATOU WASASER V CYLTIRICA
OF
LNIN LCON I THELY EAR YRSEA
WH
LYFAIRAREG RUL AAS BIS TTHEA
EITSE HOU.
TTHEIS LT ANDEE F HLE WAS
DONOGIN EHEHUG TNC EMANATIPIO
PRONMALATIOTID D N
ND E
ERSLAV AYNDAL TOTY.IT
HASO TST INENT IATPRERETNIO
GEEFRINHEN O TTH OERE SID ALL
TH
CE PEIET TSHA NDEEED TO FLAL
LIQU EALTIDU ECA AONND
GNDFUINSTNF IRAECTRUUROR
EVMU CYOMTHTYNI, D WATOR
COAT LERUTOM C LGINERATN I
TH
1E8IEIG EHTS AINOCDVAT FGOR
UAEQLIG RS.HT
DAN INK THI AND HASON DEE MOR
ATHANTHNY O PERNTSIREDE TO
EVAADNC EYALQUIT ION D'THI TNK
ANOTO MTO HYISANRISE WER
GRDISAEEO T IPINSREHE T
4t h
1ANDMEh5t A AMENDNT ONDF
CO G TSEHEATREIV CILHT RIG
LENATSLIOHEN I T S.TIIXES
OTTBU B MHENOU WLDGR AEE
SERTHE' WOR MEHAKOR TTEE NDS
BTOEE. DON
AKTO MURE O LCOINLNNCON CVIE
FO
SLKT THA BNDADROBAS IHE T
NE CANTE SALYS
'T D ION TNKHIE HOU WLD
TAHESI.TE
HE WNE H RECVED THEIR FST
TE MAPGRHSSAESGEUY BER
PRENIDT.
ANNVIS H I STIENONCEIN THE8 1
FO
AIERTS WNDASLL REAY
GGSTRUNG TO SAYT I ISBA GLOL
ICMMCOUN IIOATNS OTENSADY PFON
SPREXES ANDHE TW SLO RTEOUOU Y
ENEAR SESNGDI M TGESAS TTHAHE
SP
DEE OF.IG LHT
INDAN LVE AKBOHE T IA.DE
BE
BDESISNG IHE TRAEL TEG
PH
ROOMNHE TTE WHIOU HSE
SENDGIN A RNGEIECVI MSSAESGE
BRANDBDRY EVEERWHE.
HI TNKE HOU W HLDEAVOV LED
THEA. IDE
>> A OF TSEHOAS IDE WLDOU
APY.
SER HE'HE TRE G BATKAC
STY.
AND862O TAB EST TSHLIHED LAN
CANGRTSLEOLGE WHA TTEW KNO
ESTATRSNI UVE TIEITSAYOD.
THIR FSTTE ITIRAONHE TYLD COU
ISELL OTRAR F IMT ORRO P
CD
OMIN CHANMO TTAS WHE TONCE
PT
OF THEAN LRADGB.
ANOTEC DIRUBT SDYSIS AE W
TKNOW AAYODND THE PNCIPAL
IANMES 1 TNHE Ch9tTUENRY
FOOI DNG SNGETOMHI BIG THE
LDEFERANMOV GERIDTEN DAVTN' H
EH
OM IENC FEORNE ONG THI AND
TH
TENHESTA STEIG RS
SMEGUNT SHE TY BULHOD DENGOI
THIR F.ST
DEYIDAV HE THE ALIBITY TO
RAIS THEIT CAPAL AND AOTF O
INSMESTNTORAS W FGNEI
IN
NTSTVEME
THRAE TINCONSNTTAENLAILRD
SO WCOINLNAS AOC FUSN O
ATEDUCNIOECAUF OHE T
SH OALTFLS TFHEA ARENL O
Y
YONEORREA FDULMA E ATICAONND
TH
T REES WASEL SEARNEED H
BEME ARAW LYE AND HTU S
EI
GRINTEEATEA RR.DE
HE IASONTAT MH ANDLL AORTS
UBOF SCTJESO SE HOU W
'VLDE
ACEMBR ITHE EFADE OAN EXP
NGI
THETIDU ECAALONTE SYSNEM OF O
MANY ANDRE THE WEERTH OER
IOTEEXNSNSF OHA T ITN 2 THEh0t
UNIVESSIERTIISND A HLLRITOCA
YBL
OLKAC C CGELESUTEAM OF O
ATTH.
ATINAVENRIMECAGEOL CLEE CSAM
OUHAF O T ITNSE SUB
ENQUT
ATITER TNSIO I HNKHIELD WOU
VE LEDOV.
TANDHE VMOERNTENAT
ALIGORINPO PLYROANDSE LTGRD-AN
SIIVUNERESTI WHO KWNELNIN LCO
AASOU YNGAN MND APO PRO
DSE
THE WLEHODE I OAF THE
STINDUALRINI UYRSVEIT TGCHEAIN
TW TAS BICNGHIS OF
LTRIAGCUEUR S HEAD HS THI
IDEA FORESEC DADO TRYO TET G
ITDAS PSE85 18 BUT TNHE ITAS W
BE AEDOWNDN THE BAMECEAW L
DERINCO H BLNUTE WASER VY
WEWA AREF ORUR TNE HEAD H A
SSIV VISTORIT AHE THI WTE
HO
UREUS DHEGIN TIV CILAR W HE
WA
F ASOUAMSTIBO ALI AISONTND
ICIRONNLYAL I SHE TEAM TNOW
WHEE H GOT HISTA S WRTHIT
TH
E FAKGEOL CLEYS SMTEND A
GSINIK LE TTHA.
HA>> WOT D YOU BELVE
PR LENIDT WCOINLNDAV HE
HI
ACEDEVF I HEAS W AEBL TO
ESERVIS HON SECDER TM?
>> ITHAS THE MTOSTISS EEN
ALU
TTIESON ASKAY TOD.
LEOWNGAN HGIIT FRUS IE H
WO
CD'ULVEEDPLOMET
RENSTR ITIUCON H HFEADIV LED
LO
EERNG HOU WLDOT N ANDBAON
NON I THE8 1EN SEVESTIHA TT
LE TO THERI HORIMEBL J CWRO
TIME ISNUR OTO HISRY.AUL
NNCLIOL HHA WTOLEAV FWELOD
TH
AUGROHNE WNDIT TSSHE
PASSE O 1 TFHEthh 3t14
ANMEth15 A AMENDNT
TNGKI I ATE SPUR FERTHO TA
EN
HERESU T WREASOL PICITAL
EQITTYLI WPL CHOMEET VINOTG
RI
TSGH ANDEN GALERLYE WRE CT
FMOREI BNGHE T ITIPINSRA
THERE GATTYOC SIEGR PRO
SAM
CCOMEIL RHTSF OHE T
SIS,IE IHI TNKE HLD WOU BE
AB SO T TTHAOU THR AGHND
ADO T IT.
HE DIN TELITYOU SL OF
OALLFHO TSES LAW.
>>'M IIO CURUSOW HO YOU
EX
OAIPLNER IRNTHEETPR T
TR BTISION TWEETENAL CHEAN
EMSYSTHEND A T RYSLAI S
M?TE
LHOWG DSHA TTAK T AEND
WH
AATREHE TTA S OSGE
FDE
ENLOVEPM
SHA TT'CI F AASTINANG
TIQUES.ON
TDAN ITID DN'YEA RLL TEAK LGON
IN
ERMS OFRYIS HTOEC BSEAU
WHDEE NDEO TPE HAPORN F
RORAILOSAD TAK TE OFFHE TYAD H
MODS-ASPRAIEUC RY TL,HEAD H
TO
UT C A LOTF O TESRE ANDO T
TEACRTEHN THEEC TOGOLYO
EX
AINDTE RR OLVE AG LON
CESTDIAN.
AN TIT WHTHAAM CE
EMPRIMOVNTSEN ITEHE T SAM
GINEBRAKGINTE SYSMSA, OT L
HEOF T BSINUSESAS WEN CRED
INGOHI CCAIT WHHE TCRO INI
FCTFA ORYIS HTOHA T TTHE
NLLPUMAOMAR C CNY WNE OF O
CH BO'AGSGEIGST INDS.TRUSIE
FR
I IOMTSONEPNCTIND A
LLTELIRA T HYADUIO B ALDLLF O
ETHES OAR CSF.OU WLD
LIRANOL THELVE TULN PANLM
NRSCA IIS H SONHO WEEC BAM A
LA
ERWYAS WRE P ODESINTF THE
MAPULLPA CNOM A FNYOR WLEHI.
IERTHE ASOR HBLRIETR SEIK.
SO WTHAASN AOR IMPNTTAAR PT.
WI SVE ERYRYTORE THES I
CREMTAENL ENTVESOW H DO YOU
HA
VE A BTEETRL REATE BET
R
STRLEE ORET BTE IN?RO
TOMHETE SELIL MLSF OFR
AAGICOTS PNDIT ARGBUHNDH
ANEVCLELY TDHELL ATR CONUTIBED
WITHHEAN ADV OMECENTFHE T
LOCHTENOGYO GRO F TMHEAL CAN
18 TSRTHIIE OR 18 FTIORES
TH THEPI SSKEND AHE T GDEOLNWI
IIKSPEVE DSRIO INNT T
ONANTRSCALNETINTLR RAID.OA
A OER INT TTIESNGNGHIS
TPPHAENADYHE H TOENEI RNV
W TYHE BLDUIRI BESDGOR F THEHO
IRRA EF OT MOSER W MEEADUT O
D. WOFOO
INT TS I OSNEAT GRE
YSTORLNIN LCOEFAS W DDIENNG A
COYAN FM RKOCDSL IAN
ANOLIISDE NNDEE TDOET GIL
SSACROIVHE T R AERND ATT THA
RTIMETHTIG A THEND E OFHE T
OAEASTMBT ERAO SHE TY HAD A
TRIGHHEO T T RERIV ANDO N
ARUPSTHN TTEC AOGOLY
NNDO
RORAILOS AADCRS TER RIVO S
ETHERNS I ANC I WENIDTREHE THE
OAEASTMBHE ETITSH CRRA OEDR
TR CSTON AOLND HITHE T
GEBRID.
ESINCAST I WAD M OEFOO WD IT
TRNBUED TOHEUN GROD.
TSOHEBOTE SAMER OATWNHO W
UNRINSEDURIS HP SHIUE SSHE T
GEBRIDNYOM CPARIN I BNGN O
LISNOL A AHE TYORTTNEO T
ENPRREES B TTHE CDGRIE
PAOY
HANDES MEAK ANER INT
TIESG
MEARGU HEOESN W'TIN AE CAS
ASIT W AUN H JGYURUT B
EV
LYTUENALT I ISNE WH A
ELCOMPNGLIMETA STES TNTHI
JN'ISTT A BDGRIE ITS I AN
MEPEIMDI C TNTOEMEOMRCR O
TEAD IS I ACUB PLITYME ANIR
IT LKSINHICA AND THEAS ET
HEDAN TOUNT AOSCRSHE T
PPISSSSIIHE TYON BELOG THE T
WBLPUICUL SEHOLD BDUIOR M
E
ATHEY NREOTTO S CINPPGEMEOMRC
EOOR PROEPL FISM DNGVECORI
LAHEN I TES W WTED NEET. I
WA
S ANOR IMPNTTAAS C AEUTBO A
WH
HAEOL CERPTN O ITND A IAS W
JU
F SSTOTECIASNA HDOWE H W
WI PHE T GLIUBCDOOF O
IN
UCASFRTRRETU
>>0R 4OS P IBLSIYNRO FNT OF
RECONGLI DSSEAH WNGIT
RESTIRAONESOR F DTSNDCEENF O
WAVSLESOUTHA W LLDINLNCO
INTHK OFHA TK.QUT IC
>> IHI TNK HELD WOUHI T
NKTH
ULGHOUTF.LY
IITS APL COMEXUB SCTJE WE
OVEHA TSSDD ARESE THO
EQUIES INLL ATE SYSMS
N,ATUCIOHCEA HLTANEAR, D THE
FACT TREHE ISHE T
ENTANMROENTI JLUSCEUE ISS
ATTHOX T PICNTLASND A
RE
UNCOMM OIEITSOR CFOL
AE'ERS LHO WLEFTIS ONG THIS
INK THIIN L WLNCOLDOUAV HE
TAAMNDENDDYLL A
SSREED
USBECA S IETOKEPO TIS HEN SSE
ESAI FRNSHA TT EYALQUIT
S I
DBASEHEN O T ALIBITY TOE TAK
NTADVAE O ANTUPP OORTYNI
FDAN IOU YRE AD HELAC B FKOR
WH
REVATER ISOEAN,UL STHO BDE
AD
D.ESDRSE
HHI TNKE'VOU WLDK TEALO T
FR DICERKSGLOUAS AUTBOT I OR
TOKBOERHI W.AS ATONGN ANDLL
THEEEO PPL WHOALK AUTBOT I
DATOY.
I TNKE H WELDOU'V
HOKLOED DOWO WE DOS? THI
>> WHO WEERHE TSAN CAL
EDNAFINC?
ASEER WOM SELAPE SCUNONTI I
ETH STOCK MKEARTO SLA EXPIN
HIWHO TSAS WAN FINDCE.
>>SSHI INE OF O THE
STTEINREORG INSTFSIE O
ANERAMICAN FINCE WNHEHEY
EDNAFINCHE TYAT FLOOMED SE
SBONDHI W WCHEERBLOR HRIY
EQINADTEUA.
SE TRHOONEC STI OSF THE
LCANAHICHNAN MTEMAGEN
PEOTHRYYBAROBLOT N AD GOO
IIDEAODN T A'SAYGEOU Y HIR
ONON CR.ACTRTO
C TRHETTRONACUT OOR FID B
AN TN IHEES BTID B GRDESET
TH. JOB
TANDENYHE SOTD N OESICUT TO
IRDAN TOAY S TOSERO PMI THE
RIORPO IS GSHUYNG DOI T BE A
TOVINAGA
HA'SAT WY TTHELE CALHED TM A
TOVINAGAGI DRIG B INGTD. HYAN
T AIR F ISTT WASN A
APDEUNRCEDALITIZRO PCTJE TNHE
TH
GEYOTGNOR FEI FNGANINCIND A
TTHENLD BOUI THEAN CSAL OF
TURCOSEHED- LANANGRTYSTEM
ASIS B YALICLY GOUETHE T LDAN
AN
YOUIND THEON MEYO T
TDIL IOM SEON MEY WASAI RDSE
FO THECORA TNSTAINNTEN
LRA A
MROILAD BTLOSYUTDSON B
FTLO OGNOR FEINV ITTMESEN.
ANAST I W A REREVSEHI WLE
OENTH SOW H DOE WNJ EOY A
RENATUHEN I TID MEF T
HECI
?TY
OEATWH DSHA TT MNEA HAD WE
EODPRUCWNUR O ORG ENERY O
NECLEA A ARIRATND WERND A
ST
IKFUF L THA
OWHO DOCOU Y LIZALEHA TT?
WH D IEDCUISSSN I THEOO BK
IS CMALITE ANGHAEECFFTS
NGYTERHIERND A C
INTALY
CTEFFE OSFRA INFURRUSTCT WEE
HAUIO T B BLDDGRIESRIG HHE
IN
IGED RESNAT WERTE SYSM.
BU WHA TTLDOUE BY MT NEX
NEIGODORHBHO.DUR NHEATAL
STHO:O S TOCEMB ERA THE
TNCCOEPF OLI PUB PVATE
NEPARTHIRSP?
OKIINNG TFHEDE PANITCMI W
H
CTHETIPEOORA T OONF FHEEREDAL
MEVEGORNNDNTRM PHACAEUACTIL
CO IIEANSRE TSHENY AGYNA ALO
BA
ICKNHA TT AA?RE
>>
T INKHIO. S
ENWH AOT L OFHE TSEJE PRO
SCT
WERE DE,ON WHATEA R
YLL
IDPROV U TEDHERDERNDGIFGIN O
TH FALANINCIUC STR WRETUAS
EAC FTHE TYLD COUOL SITIC
EAURNER E IEAOPNRSESNVTO
.TH
T MEOSEDHE T FALER
VERNNTOU CLD DOT I OEDWN
MOF O THE LDANHA TT WAS
RIPRAPOPOREDAT FEAT NIV
ICAMERNDSAN AHE TYOU CLD SAY
L WWEILIV GE YOU THEAN LD.
LELITTITIT B WOAH L BNGDIDSON
BU
S ITT'OT N EUGNOH.
ITEVERNOUG YHOUAV HOE T
TFINDT RHEESF O THEON MEYO T
DO
HI TS.
WTHAT S TASHEORRYTO FLL A O
THEOAAI RLRDSHA TT CEAMFT AER
TH TNSCOTAINNTENLOAAI RLRD
HEDAN T WREASNE OE SIDTO S
RY
ORLYINIGAL AALOU JRNAMTIS NED
THE NIR FSTERSPEWAPCAYN SDI WH
A WDASDRI FENF OINCO
LNTEN
EBUTLLNTVEUA G HYE SOTOUC MH
IORMFOATHEONN  TLR RSEAIDOA
TSOJPRECUT WT HAM BEECE AN
VEST FRO F TMHE HOUAMSSEOU
INHA MANANTTF ORS COUEE HOS LT
A
RORAILADCK STOSRA CEDSHHA TTE
EV HALTULYAN FEINHODCE TSMA
.ISEDON
THTH A'SNOAT GERRERY STO.
OUHE WLDO GK BACO TMA GERN
ORVEINSTSO TAY SHI TSOAAI RLR
DO
F AURENGANINCIN I KSAANS
CI MYO, UANHTIG W TTOAK TE
ANOORHE L AKTHE TAP PER AND
THMETA STES.NT
CANELPOU YIT WHS. THI
ADHE MUGE HERO BRAKEGE FSEE
D ST ISAYESNT IERSNGTI A
ANYOD EELS
>>'T DEONETOM CPLYEL
TADEUNRSM TNDHE WND AEON W'T
S ITT'TAMP IOR TNTO SEEHA WTBU
SAW ANDEE FLT WHA HEEL F
T
TANDOESP AIRO A BTEETR
COY.TR
AILSTLTH WOROAY GN AAL MOR
PRPLCIEHA TTE W C'TAN
ABDON ITS ION W TRFDEULO
VEHAOU Y BKACH WITAL WL SEETRT
LESNDHA TNKOU Y VYERUC MH.
I>>L WIL B BEKACN IEW N
BRKYO'S IUTIS W EHDYRYVEBO
TH
EES B